who do you think has more political legs
or you know a brighter future
Andrew Cuomo the former Governor or
Chris Cuomo the former CNN pundit Chris
Cuomo became a media guy pure media guy
yeah Andrew I think still has legs what
do you think Pat I know you were big
fans of them during the pandemic
listen for me obviously you know what
what the whole cover-up brother all that
stuff that you know Chris got criticism
for which it's his brother what do you
think he's going to do he's gonna sit
there and when he's praying at night and
he's talking to his dad you know and his
obviously his dad's no longer here but
when he's talking to his dad praying
whatever you're doing and saying hey
what should I do that you back up your
brother what do you think Mario his
father told Chris and Andrew when they
were small saying hey you guys better
back each other up 100 till the day I
die you better back each other so I
don't see Mario as a lightweight father
I see him as a strong wasn't he a
two-term governor or something like that
he was supposed to be a president and he
chose not to run last minute and some
people said it was a big mistake because
if he would have ran he would have been
a president he still didn't want to make
the decision to run this is not look
just look at the way he looks
he's a tough he's a boss yeah he's the
kind of a dad that would raise some
tough guys yeah so to me
I don't know I think Andrew uh is
sitting around saying you know the Cuomo
people remember today is not Mario Cuomo
the Cuomo people know today no today the
only people that know Mario Cuomo
they're probably 50 plus okay 60 plus
and they're gonna go away yeah and
they're in New York right the Cuomo
people know today is the two brothers
those two guys to be honest with you
here's what I would do if I was those
two guys this is what I would do
I would sign them in a heartbeat I would
sign them in a heartbeat right now if
they did a show together two brothers
and I'd give them a nice amount per year
and could do show the two brothers you
got so much history of what to talk
about with you know and you there'd be
plenty of guests that would be willing
to come on your show and I think people
on the right will be willing to come on
your shelves you don't need CNN to these
guys they think like that's the place to
be CNN MSNBC CBS ABC those guys
own you guys if you go do something like
that go take the podcast route do a show
together and leave a different kind of a
legacy of hey here's where I screwed up
here's what I did with this but let me
tell you guys the experience we got
here's what our father raised they can
talk how their father raised them they
can talk Brothers they can talk family
nucleus they can talk Italian stories
they can talk food they can talk who's
better with the mom who's a bigger
mama's boy they can talk so many
different things they're the kind of
guys that you know I have friends in my
life that I fully disagree with
politically but my gosh I enjoy having
dinner with them right those will be
these guys I think they're very
marketable uh I don't know these guys
I've never the only thing I think one
time we had a communication trying to
get Chris here and he asked for a big
number to be I'm like dude we're not
doing that we just want you to be on the
podcast or not anyways that was a
different experience that we had
together but I am a very uh big fan of
them on the way they are with their
families okay again someone's going to
come back and say you don't know what
they are let me take their backgrounds
tied to the Mob all this stuff stop if
you walk on water fine all I'm saying to
you is they're very marketable these are
two marketable guys that can do
something with their legacy and
if I was a son of a Cuomo and Mario's my
dad okay and I'm talking uh having a
conversation in my head with my dad my
dad I'm gonna be like hey man there's no
way in the world you gave us this last
name we're gonna let our last name end
the way it is ending right now and the
same people that we brought all these
eyeballs for Andrew Cuomo did all this
stuff for New York Chris Cuomo did all
this stuff for CNN all of those eyeballs
you about now they want to crucify you
and hurt your last name oh hell to the
no so but that's me yeah I don't know
how they're going to handle it but I
think that'd be a great thing not to cut
you off Adam I just just really fast I
think that something like that where
people that were on like CNN and they're
just all the left going on a network or
going like on a podcast that you don't
have to read a script you know I mean
you don't have to be a political
activist just we want to talk to you I
want to know how you guys are you guys
remembered in the pandemic uh I think
Chris did a joke about his brother
having a big nose I mean it was during
where you know people were dying in like
uh old person homes but he he was like
Hey with your brother puts like a big
Q-tip making fun of his nose that
Dynamic that brother Dynamic would be
something great to see not on a CNN it's
it's it's it's it's it's for TV now by
the way you know Christmas podcast is
not doing that good right now you know
because you know you it there's okay so
the world of TV here's a question here's
a question to ask okay so guys that play
traditional basketball who they play
fundamental basketball okay and they go
play street ball and give me the top
Place rocker park or they go play in
Venice Beach and you're playing with
some tough tough guys right fundamental
basketball is one thing playing with
tough men who are gonna elbow you hurt
you talk to you if you're playing
for a Christian basketball league and
then you go there it's a major shocker
when you do that right okay fighting in
a organized ring boxing with gloves
versus go to Thailand or go to certain
places where they're doing
um
kicking your street brawl thousand
dollar bets five thousand dollar bets
it's a very different climate Okay doing
TV on CNN Fox your team has got 40
employees whose job is to make you look
good okay the teleprompter the script
the writer the stories the person
telling you you're reminding about this
remember November 28 when he said this
he said this 19 years ago and you seem
so smart because someone's no one's
feeding us right now the only thing
we hear is our own voice yeah this is
hard oh yeah so to go from there to
doing this super hard by the way it's
also hard for people to go from podcasts
to do what Chris and them do you know
why because we're long-winded
I don't know if you understand what I'm
saying of course you got to keep it
lighting time like when I'm a damn
bongino it's like hey so so Pat hey so
Patrick we got 30 seconds left okay
go that's that's a different format big
time so so for us to make that
transition there is not easy for them to
make the transition here it's not easy
we don't like mainstream because that's
not how life is life to me is an
explanation of what you're going through
may take 18 minutes I don't give a
about commercial Cuts we got to cut to
commercials here's Pfizer take some more
such and such all right and if your
thing lasts more than four hours with
Cialis call a doctor we're back here so
let me tell you what Kamala Harris said
that's a freaking so for us what do you
think Tom what do you think about this
rap how do you think so so this is the
part with Chris going from mainstream to
podcasts very few people know like
Russell Brand is a great podcaster but
he tried to go have his own TV show it
flopped yeah it's it's not it's not uh
even movies he had a shot with movies
too it was like ah wow he came in and
came out he did have a major hit though
inside of you who are inside of you what
you're so bad yeah Forgetting Sarah
Marshall I I know what I'm saying is he
had like little guest star rules but
what are you trying to do what are you
talking about this song was a hit
out of control can you not do it song
was amazing but then he tried to be like
in the movie Arthur and I mean get into
the Greek his career shirt oh my God
he's so freaking Speaking of Chris Cuomo
I just went and because I knew you were
going to go talk because he does have a
podcast it launched almost a year ago I
think in uh April of 2022 so it's been
nine months look at the guests that
Chris Cuomo can get he doesn't get a ton
of views a couple of his yeah only two
videos of over a hundred thousand views
two yeah he doesn't but here's the guess
that Chris Cuomo has had on his podcast
talk about a-listers Bill Maher Whoopi
Goldberg our good friend Neil deGrasse
Tyson Stephen A Smith Sean Penn Alec
Baldwin anybody he'll get what Tyler
Perry Joe manchin Andrew Yang Paul
manafort our old friend over there your
friend Noam Chomsky Bob Costas I mean Dr
Phil Tulsi gabbard dude gets but no
iPhone but no eyeballs he's like in the
basement so Chris if you're watching
Valentine would like to have a
conversation yeah cool well almost bring
your brother why not listen obviously
this is not a pitch they're gonna they
gotta go to the people that they're
comfortable with because that's where
they got to go but all I'm saying is if
I was somebody
that was in a safe space for them that
they would want to go create content
with I would in a heartbeat picture show
between the two of them together I put
the show between two of them together
and throw middle host you know somebody
like in a you know that's and then they
can do whatever they want to do people
come up current events politics business
stories family everything yeah all right
anyways hopefully we got them a job okay
so if you enjoyed this club you want to
see another one click here to watch
another clip and if you want to take
advantage the latest gold Signature
Series products that just came out we
have a bunch of new merch that's out
this is a color changing mug when you
drink coffee that lion turns into a real
lion and then we have hoodies with
Valium and gold on it the gold Signature
Series hat shirts I'm an entrepreneur
anyways we have a lot of items they're
selling out if you want to take
advantage the gold Signature Series
click here place your order Sports your
right taming gear and tag us with the
hashtag valuetainment
[Music]